there was a very scary
insurrectionist nation-threatening march
in washington dc over the weekend
you might have seen it trending on
twitter this was the march of the
patriot front so-called a group
allegedly of fascists and white
supremacists and they marched through dc
and the media oh they had a field day
and they said this is
the white supremacist takeover of
america and you can't really see who any
of these people are
and they're wearing masks and they're
marching and they've got flags some of
the flags are upside down to signal
distress and
my first reaction
was that this was fed picnic part two
you know do you remember there was the
justice for january sixth rally and the
only people who showed up were feds and
media and like one
right-wing dude who didn't get the memo
that it was all fake
and so i that was my first reaction was
look i'm
on the american right i spend a lot of
time in the american right i
i've been in it for a long time i'm
familiar with lots of fringe groups okay
even the ones that are way out there i'm
at least familiar with them i've never
heard of this group have you the patriot
front of the white supremacist national
whatever
no
so was it a fed thing or what or is it
real i don't know maybe it's real
even assuming for a second
that this is a real group
and there aren't any feds and it's not
fake and not just immediate contrivance
ask yourself this what
what poses a bigger risk to you
a bunch of
clowns marching through the streets not
harming anybody
making a big show and giving the media a
circus but not
not burning down any stores or killing
people or assaulting people just kind of
marching
marching around and going home
probably back to quantico or
langley or something but you know
whatever what does that pose
the big bigger threat to you or does say
uh blm and antifa with the support of
the entire media and elected democrats
for six months burning down the country
does that pose the bigger threat
what's the real threat here because
according to the establishment
blm which killed dozens of people and
torched cities around the country and
stole a lot of gucci handbags
blm was mostly peaceful and according to
the media those guys whose identities we
don't know conveniently
those guys marching peacefully for a few
hours they are an insurrectionist threat
to destroy the country
obviously
the narrative seems a little bit
backward hold up
i'm glad you like that clip
before you do anything nope before you
even think ring that bell
ring it please
thank you that way you'll get the
notifications and if our friends
here
don't want to give you the notifications
as sometimes happens head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show t-h-e space m-i-c-h-a-e-l space
canon w-l-e-s space s-h-o-w period
subscribe to the michael knowles show
evil 5 star review see you next time
[Music]
[Music]